[Music]
the next group the next two speakers
George Clark and Bill crush are are two
of the very productive group that Fred
described in in his talk the cosmic ray
group the remarkable thing about that
group was to see with what insight it
moved from one related series of
experiments to another again I won't go
through what Fred described so well but
moving from looking at the primary
radiation to using the cosmic rays to
try to look for the origin of cosmic
rays and then moving to essentially a
succession of experiments that look at
cosmological questions in it it has been
an inspiration to to watch George who
speaks first specialized particularly an
x-ray sources and the measurements of
x-ray sources has worked I think was
flew the balloon experiment that saw the
x-rays from the Crab Nebula is that and
then a sequence of experiments our
various satellites and observatories so
let me turn to George
I was a johnny-come-lately when I joined
the MIT cosmic-ray group it was a
flourishing enterprise in the laboratory
for nuclear science and engineering when
I joined as a graduate student in 1950 I
was put to work experimenting with the
new scintillation counters and when I
finished my degree
professor rossi invited me on a journey
of exploration that would be guided by
his unerring sense of scientific
opportunity that sense and the gentle
firm hand with which he steered the
cosmic ray group into the future had
already established MIT as a center for
the exploration of cosmic physics and
high-energy particle physics now this
first slide is the jacket cover of his
recent autobiography it's a bit dim but
I think you can see in that gray the
young Rossi pointing into that future
from a perch on top of the mountain
where he discovered the radioactive
decay of the muon in 1939 and just
beside him is his energetic wife Nora
who's helped many of Bruno's young
associates over life's rough spots
professor Rossi had laid the foundations
in the 1930s for rapid progress in
cosmic ray research after the war in
1929 he was a 24 year old assistant in
the physics laboratory in the University
of Florence and he was looking around
for something new and interesting to do
in physics and then he read the paper of
botha and called her stir about a
coincidence experiment on the
penetrating power of cosmic rays Rossi
tells how he was galvanized by a desire
to improve on that experiment and to
begin his own exploration of what was a
virgin
field of physics within a few weeks he
had invented the first coincident
circuit there was a device that employed
the new technology of triode vacuum
tubes and it was soon known throughout
the nuclear physics world as the rossi
coincident circuit that invention
initiated the application of electronic
methods in cosmic ray and particle
physics and it was the precursor of the
and logic circuits of modern electronic
computers when he began his work in 1930
it was generally believed that the
primary cosmic rays were gamma rays and
the famous Robert Millikan held that
they were gamma rays born in what he
called the birth cries of the atoms
synthesized by some mysterious process
in interstellar space the binding energy
of the most massive nucleus is some half
a billion electron volts put a rather
severe limit on the possible energy of
the gamma rays and then with Geiger
tubes and this new coincidence circuit
Rossi carried out a series of momentous
experiments that demolished those ideas
here is a very brief summary of those of
those remarkable experiments first he
demonstrated that the existence of
penetrating charged particles with more
than a billion electron volts exists in
cosmic rays and they're capable of
traversing a metre of lead the particles
which were subsequently identified as
muons in this experiment he had as the
three geiger tubes connected in
coincidence and a total of one meter of
lead through which they could penetrate
secondly he discovered what came to be
known as the Rossi transition effect
which illuminated the production of
multiplicative showers and stimulated
development of the quantum theory of
electron photon Cascades
in this case the three geiger tubes were
placed in the triangular array so that
they could only be triggered by more
than one particle in third he measured
the east-west difference in the cosmic
ray intensity which he had predicted in
1930 and a theoretical analysis of the
different effect of the Earth's magnetic
field on the trajectories of positive
and negative particles the experiment is
illustrated in the bottom where the V
Geiger tube telescope is pointed to the
east and then to the west actually
others using this coincidence method
beat him to the actual discovery by a
few months in 1934 but in any case the
results proved that the primary cosmic
rays are mostly positively charged
particles probably protons and in
addition in the course of that east-west
experiment he discovered that what he
characterized in his 1934 publication as
very extensive showers of cosmic ray
particles in the open air it was a
phenomenon that would occupy the MIT
cosmic ray group 20 years later
professor rossi told me recently and
perhaps with a bit of nostalgia that
those were simple experiments yet his
results were so startling that he had
trouble getting some of them published
they did not earn him the friendship of
robert millikan but they did indeed
change the direction of cosmic ray and
particle physics and they won him a
professorship at the university of
padova at an early age in 1938 the
fascists forced rossi from his position
as the director of the institute of
physics that he'd created at Padua he
left Italy and after a year in
Copenhagen in Manchester he and Nora
came to Chicago at the invitation of
Arthur Compton Rossi had an idea about
how to detect the possible radioactive
decay of what were called in those days
Misa Tron's
those were the particles of penetrating
radiation that he had measured in the
early 30s and which had recently been
identified by Street and Stevenson at
Harvard as particles with a mass of
about a 200 times the mass of the
electron
he built new equipment to measure the
intensity of misa Tron's and he took it
to Colorado where he operated it at
various altitudes on Mount Evans he
proved that mrs. roms do indeed suffer
radioactive decay by showing that their
intensity is reduced more by passage
through a given thickness of air than by
passage through an equivalent thickness
of graphite the difference is due to the
loss of Metatron's by radioactive decay
during their time of flight through the
tenuous atmosphere and that result was
the first demonstration of the
instability of a subatomic particle
other than the neutron and it gave a
rough value for the mean life of the
order of a microsecond in 1940 Rossi
moved to Cornell where he and Harrison
measured that precise mean life of the
stop Meza Tron's in a classic particle
decay experiment which was the first of
its kind for which he invented the
electronic device now known as a time to
amplitude converter and in this figure
you see the beautiful exponential decay
curves of positive mesons that have been
brought to rest first in LED and then in
brass then came his work at Los Alamos
which culminated in an experiment at the
Trinity test where he measured the
exponential rise of ionization in an ion
chamber placed next to the detonating
plutonium bomb he used a technique that
was known at Los Alamos as the Rossi
sweep it was one in which he applied a
high-frequency sinusoid to the vertical
deflection
and in fact he was using the fastest
oscilloscope available in the country at
the time so the beam of the oscilloscope
was sitting there oscillating in the
vertical direction behind a mask to
avoid over exposing the film the signal
from the ion chamber was applied to the
horizontal deflection so when the bomb
went off the beam of the oscilloscope
was driven to the right at an
exponentially increasing speed which
could be measured directly in terms of
the frequency of the vertical
oscillation the figure shows that sweep
and below the actual photograph from the
Trinity test in which the split second
between the pre and post atomic age is
frozen as a faint trace of the signal
from the ion chamber before it was
vaporized and you can see just here the
first couple of oscillations of the
vertical of the vertical oscillation as
the as the ionization drives the beam
across the face of the oscilloscope so
that was the prologue to the Rossi era
at a my laboratory for nuclear science
which Fred Epling has sketched and as
Fred said there were four young
physicists that came with Rossi from Los
Alamos Herbert bridge Matthew Sands
Robert Thompson and Robert Williams they
were soon joined by John tin Lowe and
Robert hull sizer who had worked at the
MIT radiation laboratory and though they
came as PhD students they were already
experienced researchers who were quite
ready to tackle the problems of cosmic
rays in the kind of independent and
collegial way that has been an enduring
characteristic of the cosmic ray group
Rossi defined two research themes both
extensions of his previous cosmic ray
research the first were the theme was
the nuclear interactions of cosmic rays
and the particles generated in these
interactions and the second was the
composition and properties of the
primary radiation
and one should recall what wasn't wasn't
known in 1946 from the east-west
experiment it was known that the primary
radiation is mostly positively charged
particles probably protons with energies
that extend beyond 10 GeV unknown was
the presence of heavy nuclei and
electrons at the level of about 1% and
there were Inklings of radio waves and
solar x-rays but the richness of the non
visible spectrum from Radio to
high-energy gamma rays was quite
unexpected
as for the cosmic radiation in the
atmosphere it was known to consist first
of all of a soft component of electrons
and photons that are readily absorbed in
a few centimeters of lead there was a
hard component of penetrating particles
the Metatron's capable of traversing
great thicknesses of lead unscathed and
there was a component capable of
generating showers of penetrating
particles that can be detected by a
raise of geiger tubes that are buried in
a pile of lead in particle physics there
were five so-called fundamental
particles protons neutrons electrons
neutrinos what were called Misa Tron's
and one antiparticle the positron those
Metatron's which are now called muons
were thought to be the glue of nuclear
force predicted by yahwah but doubts had
been raised by recent experiments that
showed they hardly interacted all with
the nuclei with the nuclei that they
were supposed to glue unknown where the
pion and the zoo of particles and
antiparticles made from quarks that
constitute our current world of the
standard model cyclotrons could provide
experimenters with protons of several
tens of MeV
but machines capable of creating
anything heavier than electrons were
still several years in the future now
certainly many groups and individuals
around the world contributed to the
remarkable progress in the next 15 years
but in this short time I obviously can't
do justice
so complex a history and so with
apologies concentrated on the
contributions from the Rossi group first
question addressed was what is the cause
of those penetrating showers in in
particular are they generated by meso
Tron's jaunt in low put that idea to
rest by measuring the rate of
penetrating showers as a function of
altitude he took his detectors up and
down Mount Evans and even to higher
altitudes in a b-29 and he found that
the rate of penetrating shower
production increases much more rapidly
with altitude than the message Ron
intensity so the cause of the
penetrating showers could not be
measured Ron's indeed it had to be
either the primary protons themselves or
the secondary nucleons which they
generate in interactions with air nuclei
and a similar experiment done ten years
earlier by Rossi and DeBenedetti at
Padua had showed that the bezu had shown
that the meso Tron's do not cause the
soft showers of electrons in photons so
the question became what is the
connection between the interactions of
energetic nucleons and the soft
component of electrons and photons well
in a separate approach to this problem
her bridge began to build multi-plate
cloud chambers with which the tracks of
charged particles are made visible as
trails of droplets he set up a chamber
under a penetrating shower detector near
Echo Lake on Mount Evans in a laboratory
situated at 10,000 feet in pine woods
that are frequented by year deer and and
elk but meanwhile in 1947 particle
physics began to get more complicated
Giuseppe a Chiellini who was professor
Rosie's first Italian student was
working at that time with Powell and
lattice inputs in Bristol England late
one night he recovered a nuclear
emulsion from the trash where had been
discarded
apparently due to the hopeless
overexposure to cosmic rays in in a
laboratory that had been high in the
Alps examining the nearly opaque
emulsion under a microscope
he discovered the track of a PI meson
that stopped and decayed into a Mumma
zone and within a year two more unstable
particles heavier than pi ons the
so-called V particles were discovered in
cloud chamber pictures at the by
Rochester and Butler in Manchester so
bridge and his associates joined the
search for these new particles with
their the V particles were quickly
confirmed and in 1949 the first examples
of camus ons were discovered in the form
of what were called s particles
so here is a picture showing a typical s
particle event as the track of a
particle which enters from above stops
in the sixth plate after scattering and
the increased ionization and the
increased deflection show that it stops
in this plate and from the point of
stopping there emerges a penetrating
particle that goes out the bottom of the
chamber analysis of that scattering of
the particle as it comes to rest shows
that the s particle mass lay between
that of the proton and the pion and that
the mean life was longer than ten to the
minus nine seconds those are properties
of the Kame essence and this was the
first example of this of the came as on
that was published and that's about the
time that I joined the cosmic great
group is a new graduate student I
remember the all-night Labor's of mark
nanus as he scanned the films and stan
dolberg
as he worked on out the statistical
theory of scattering and energy loss of
stopped particles Stan was a pole and
the veteran of the Warsaw Uprising he
came to MIT as a graduate student
sponsored by an MIT fraternity and
somehow he'd managed to study
theoretical physics and after the
release from a prisoner of war camp in
Germany and so he arrived at MIT
well-equipped to provide the theoretical
support needed to in the particle
research his 40 year old results on
stopped
particles are used even today in precise
planning of treatments of retinal
cancers with stopped protons at the
Harvard cyclotron that was by a twist of
fate that professor Ober he himself was
a recent and much honored patient at
that facility
now bridge and his associates continued
their search in cloud chamber
photographs for clues to the origin of
the soft electron photon showers they
found what they were looking for in
pictures this show in neutral link
between a nuclear interaction and an
electron shower now in 1947 robert
Oppenheimer had suggested on theoretical
grounds that the intermediary and
electron showers might be an ultra
short-lived neutral pion that decays
into a pair of photons John tin Lowe and
Bernard Gregory used a cloud chamber
with brass plates that would allow a
photon to escape from the region of its
creation in one plate and then
materialized in another plate from to
form an electron-positron pair leaving a
visible gap or a neutral link between
the interaction in the and the start of
the electron shower now examples of such
neutral links can be seen in this quite
remarkable cloud chamber pictured here a
particle enters center stage from above
it passes through six plates and stops
in this plate as one can see by the
increasing ionization and increasing
deflection to small electron showers
emerge from the seventh and the eighth
plate respectively and their directions
dive diverge directly from this point of
interaction in the in the in this brass
plate and their total energy is more
than 300 million electron volts there
are no tracks linking the two downward
showers to that point of interaction and
so the physical links therefore must be
high-energy photons that carry no charge
and therefore leave no track but do
materialize into electron pairs
Gregory tin Lowe and Rossi had found
numerous examples of such neutral links
by 1949 when they published their
conclusion
that pairs of energetic photons arise
from the decay of neutral particles of
intermediate mass probably neutral pion
produced directly in high-energy
interactions so the mystery of the
origin of soft component was solved by
the verification of the Oppenheimer idea
and in the following year experiments at
the Berkeley synchrotron provided the
detailed evidence of threshold
production and coincidence detection of
these decay photons that confirmed the
existence of the neutral pion but this
picture is specially remarkable because
because it contains the first evidence
for annihilation of a heavy antiparticle
looking more carefully at this track
where what you one sees that the
deflections are increasing and that the
ionization is particularly heavy meaning
that it's going slowly here as I said
before proves that the particle stopped
in this plate well since it came to rest
it obviously did not have any kinetic
energy to give to those electron showers
that pass downward and to the left but
more spectacular is the energetic
electrons our that emerges from the six
plate and travels upward and to the
right its energy alone was estimated at
eleven hundred and seventy million
electron volts and thus the total energy
emerging from that stop point exceeded
1.4 GeV more than the rest energy of a
single photon in their 1954 publication
the authors concluded that the event is
an annihilation of a heavy antiparticle
either an antiproton or an anti hyper
and an annihilation with a nucleon in
the brass and within a year Chamberlain
and C gray had identified anti protons
among the products of high-energy
interactions at the nuclear at the
berkeley bevatron one final bit of
particle physics was extracted from
cosmic rays in 1957 before we abandon
them for the greener fields of space
astronomy
Juan Herzl who was visiting from Bolivia
and I following a suggestion of Bob
Williams actually based on the recent
discoveries of parity violation and beta
decay we measured the polarization of
cosmic ray muons in what is truly a
tabletop experiment perhaps the last one
of its kind in cosmic or nearly one of
the last one of its kind in cosmic rays
and that we set up in a lab in building
six hail abroad and extended the
experiment in a greatly enlarged version
carried out in an old limestone mine
near Poughkeepsie where they cultivate
mushrooms his measurements of muon
polarization as a function of depth
underground cast light on the production
of pie on sand chaos and nuclear
interactions of cosmic rays and the
energy range from 10 to 100 GeV but the
complexity and the ambiguity of the
analysis that was required to extract
something of value was just another
symptom of the end of cosmic rays as a
useful source in particle physics but
now I want to go back to 1946 and the
second of the Rossi research themes Bob
Williams had set out to determine the
energy spectrum of primary particles by
measuring the size distribution of
extensive air showers he built an array
of pulse ion chambers like those rossi
had used in the trinity experiment and
from the pattern of pulse amplitudes
recorded when the the array was struck
by an extensive air shower williams
could locate the core of the shower he
could then compute the total number of
particles and from that he could
estimate the energy of the primary
particle in 1947 Williams published his
results on the detection of showers of
up to a hundred million particles
initiated by primaries with energies up
to 10 to the 17th electron volts and
that was an astonishing extension of the
primary spectrum
and a challenge two theories about the
origin and propagation of cosmic rays in
the galaxy now in the summer of 1952
Peter bossy came as a visitor from
potowa Institute that Rossi had started
before the war and I was just finishing
my thesis
professor rossi suggested to us that we
explore the possibility of determining
the arrival directions of air showers by
timing the arrival of the particles over
an array of timing detectors new liquid
scintillators made it possible to build
cheap large fast proportional counters
and we took russy's suggestion to heart
and soon had a linear array of three
liquid scintillation detectors set up on
the roof of building six our results
demonstrated that showers are do in fact
arrive as flat pancakes of particles
about a meter thick moving with the
speed of light just right to allow a
determination of the arrival directions
by a simple geometrical analysis of the
differences in the arrival times several
of us then began a program of air shower
experiments to determine the energy
spectrum and celestial arrival
directions of primaries up to the
highest energy that nature could
generate we felt there must be a high
energy cutoff somewhere perhaps near 10
to the 18th electron volts where the
magnetic confinement of the galaxies of
the galaxy should spring a leak or
perhaps at 10 to the 19th where protons
are degraded by interactions with
starlight surely there would be a
telltale and I saw trippy at
sufficiently high energy that the radius
of curvature of the primary particles in
the weak magnetic field of the galaxies
is comparable to the thickness of the
Galactic disk so we built an array of 11
large scintillation counters filled with
flammable toluene set it out in the dry
forests of the Agassi station of the
Harvard College Observatory and as Fred
mentioned we did overcome many problems
including rabbits chewing on the
voltage cables and a little problem with
fire in a detector struck by lightning
well the observatory in fact did not
burn down the scintillator was replaced
with discs of homemade plastic
scintillator and the powers that be
allowed us to proceed signals were
displayed on a bank of oscilloscopes
whenever several of the detectors were
struck by an air shower we photographed
photographed those oscilloscopes
transferred the particle density and
arrival time data to punched tape and
analyzed it on the newly liberated
whirlwind computer and we measured the
primary spectrum up to 10 to the 18th
electron volt here one sees the largest
shower that was detected at Agassiz it
lit up all of the detectors in this
array which was nearly half a kilometer
in diameter and after analysis on the
computer we could fit a lateral
distribution curve to the particle
densities and derived from that the size
of the shower and infer the energy of
the primary particle which was in excess
of 10 to the 18th electron volts a good
fraction of one Joule but there was no
trace of anisotropy and no trace of a
cutoff in the energy spectrum I set up a
small air shower array in the south of
India fruitless search for anisotropy in
the southern hemisphere where the center
of the galaxy is visible we sent the
entire Agassiz experiment with the
cooperation of Ismail Escobar to the
Altiplano in Bolivia to improve the
statistical accuracy of the search in
the southern hemisphere
still no anisotropy and finally John
Linsley and Livio Skaar C carried the
air shower enterprise another giant step
forward with a huge array on the volcano
ranch near Albuquerque here you see the
volcano array which is which was finally
three kilometers in diameter dwarfing
the previous arrays and in their
measurements their spectrum reach
10 to the 20th electron volts and where
we've missed this is a displayed here
where we've multiplied it where I've
multiplied the intensity by the cube of
the energy to flatten the steep spectrum
out in one sees that the data extend
clear to 10 to the 20th electron volts
and just think 10 to the 20th electron
volts is 6 joules that's the energy
required to raise a one-pound weight for
feet and that's a truly astonishing
amount of kinetic energy to be carried
by a single particle and the mystery
still remains where do they come from as
air shower research approached a point
of diminishing returns and accelerators
replaced cosmic rays as sources for
high-energy particle physics two new
lines of research opened up that have
occupied the cosmic ray group ever since
high-energy photon astronomy and
interplanetary plasma physics Sputnik
flew in October of 57 and you could hear
its beep beep on the shortwave radio as
it passed over Cambridge in the ensuing
panic Rossi was asked to chair a
committee of the National Academy that
met in the summer of 1958 to examine the
possibilities for space science on
satellites he found little interest
anywhere in the possibilities of cosmic
x-rays or interplanetary plasma so he
decided to initiate action himself the
cosmic ray group was already at work on
a satellite gamma ray astronomy project
that had been initiated in the spring of
1958 by Bill Crouch our so Rossi brought
his ideas about x-ray astronomy to his
former student Martin Anas who had just
started a research company in Cambridge
called American science and engineering
Martin decided to commit a portion of
the company's meager resources to a
paper study into a preparation of
proposals to NASA and to the Air Force
that effort led by riccardo giacconi
succeeded with the discovery of the
first x-ray star by a rocket experiment
in 1962 that was in fact sponsored by
the US Air Force and soon after that
several of us had started work in x-ray
astronomy at Mi
tea but that's a another long and
complex story that I won't attempt to
tell now during that summer of 1958
Rossi discussed his idea about space
plasmas with her bridge here you see
them examining a test setup in the
laboratory where they were exploring the
possibilities of measuring plasmas in
space now in 1957 Eugene Parker's
Chicago had published his theory of an
expanding solar corona that blows past
earth as a supersonic wind of ionized
hydrogen there were observations of
multiple Comet tail's that had been
interpreted as an effect of supersonic
wind so it was clearly a matter of great
interest to test these ideas by direct
measurements bridge and Rossi
immediately started development of a
device that could be carried on a
deep-space mission to measure the energy
spectrum and flow direction of tenuous
plasma here you see in this picture you
see them examining that one of those
test setups and Rossi succeeded in
securing a place on Explorer 10 for the
first MIT LNS plasma probe Explorer 10
was NASA's first attempt to send a
spacecraft to a large distance from the
earth now of course by that time the
Soviets had sent a spacecraft to the
vicinity of the moon the Soviets had
carried a sensor that did in fact detect
plasma but gave no information about its
flow direction and little about its
density and energy and I was at the Cape
Canaveral in March of 1961 waiting for
the upcoming launch of the MIT gamma ray
experiment when the preceding experiment
Explorer 10 roared into space on its
elongated orbit I remember the
excitement in the ground station when
the first signals of a space plasma came
through as the detector on the rotating
satellite repeatedly passed the
direction of the Sun
here you see the picture of the plasma
probe which carries over here of the
Explorer 10 satellite which carries the
MIT LNS plasma probe designed to capture
and analyze the stream of plasma that
might be encountered analysis showed
over that over the course of several
hours the on its outward journey the
plasma probe had detected alternating
conditions of no plasma and of a
supersonic plasma blowing away from the
Sun the the satellite rotated and as
they carried the plasma probe past the
direction of the Sun which is indicated
by these vertical lines a signal of a
supersonic plasma flow was was received
and by good luck that trajectory
happened to be along the wavy boundary
between the region of space dominated by
the Earth's magnetic field and a region
of steady flow of the solar wind that's
now known as the magneto sheath Explorer
10 had made what turned out to be the
first measurements of the solar wind
that can indeed confirm the Parker
theory and it had penetrated the
boundary of the Earth's magnetosphere
several more plasma probe experiments
were developed in LNS before the work
was moved to the Center for Space
Research where it flourishes today MIT
plasma probes of ever greater
sophistication have explored the magneto
spheres of all the planets out to
Neptune solar wind measurements are
still received from Voyager 1 and 2
which are now on their way out of a
solar system at velocities of more than
20,000 miles per hour
sometime early in the next century their
trajectories will pierce the boundary of
the heliosphere and provide the first
direct measurements of the fields and
particles in the pristine interstellar
medium a kind of scientific gift from
this generation of space scientists to
the next
the Rossi era in the laboratory for
nuclear science and later in the Center
for Space Research has been a truly
wonderful 46 year journey of exploration
exploration at the frontiers of particle
physics and space science I know I speak
for all who have shared it with Bruno
whom I'm delighted to see here today and
I want us for all of those people I want
to say to him thanks for bringing us
along thank you
[Applause]